hey guys it is Friday which means my
gonna go over some of the biggest things
to happen to in gaming this weekend let
you know what we think about them and be
sure to weigh em down in that comment
section but for now here's what we
thought Jess what's the most popular
multiplayer honor at the moment
Battle Royale what's and what's a game
that you haven't thought about in a
little while that involves parkour and
zombies die life okay could we possibly
mash those together well I mean it is
kind of happening not quite that battle
royale level but um a expansion is
coming up and doing like cold bad blood
yes that bad but not the Taylor Swift
one and basically what its gonna do is
provide a way for PvP to be injected
into the game taglines has said that bad
blood is their response to the recent
popularity of the Battle Royale genre
but the mode will only be for six
players so it blends PvP with PvE
un5 on the players I jumped into a
hostile area you're fighting a bunch of
zombies but at the same time you have to
evacuate before night falls so you're
gonna want to be scavenging for weapons
while harvesting blood samples from the
infected so you can align with other
players against zombies but at the same
time you can also turn on those allies
to steal their samples and then
ultimately the more samples you harvest
the more evacuation states on the
chopper are unlocked but everyone pays
for their own seat individually so if
you want to play nice or you want to
play not so nice
that's up to you it's a cool kind of
like mashup of battle royale and the
divisions dog sounds really cool I think
it works well for them that they're not
just like he's going the hundred play
route yeah nice to see them doing
something that fits their game a little
better
um but yeah if you're a fan of dying
life that's gonna be something to look
forward to sounds like it should be
arriving sometime in 2018 oh boy it's
the season of giving yes it is it is for
once I got something right Ubisoft as
well in the giving spirit they're giving
away two free games this month in
December and also you can get into a
free free beta a free beta a free beta
that's starting tomorrow you can get
into the Monster Hunter World beta on
ps4 and run around to two locations and
there's three missions where you can
hunt a bunch of weird giant monsters
that have really funny names that I'm
not even
to attempt to say but you'll need
PlayStation Plus to take part in that
yeah and about six gigabytes of free
space but you can play it through it all
solo or with through up to three of your
buds and if all the missions you
complete you will unlock a reward in the
full game when it comes out so what's
the hunter world beta get into that on
ps4 this weekend and if you've got if
you've got a PC yeah if you're more a PC
person um as Dan said Ubisoft are giving
away a seventh grade Black Flag is
starting in a few days time ah yes
starting on the 12th yes but right now
you can pick up world of conflict and
both of those are totally free on PC the
only thing you're gonna need is a you
play account and then you can just
download them and to keep them so you're
looking for something to play over the
holidays yeah I would recommend welding
conflict it's pretty cool it's a good
RTS and then of course I still think
Black Flag is the best Assassin's Creed
yes just because the whole time the main
character makes fun of all the dumbest
ass and stuff and I think that's really
cool and also his parts and sailing
ships around and sea shanties oh man
play that sir Dan the Internet is mad
the only mad for a few days well I mean
I think it's pretty justified to be
honest I was mildly appalled when I saw
this story
um so obviously right now is a really
bad time to be a developer who does not
appear to be consumer friendly oh boy
what's basically happened with destiny -
with the curse of exciter Service iris
expansion coming out is that some
content that was previously accessible
towards end slash late game is now
locked behind the paywall of actually
owning the deal sort of behind the
paywall so what happens with what
happened with the curse of Osiris
expansion it increased the level cap and
also the power level cap so it went from
20 to 25 and I think the power level is
now 350 or something like that
so some of the higher end activities
have seen their level caps raised more
in line with the new level caps but
people who didn't you know jump on the
curse of a cyrus bandwagon I've now
found they can't access being like
prestige nightfall
prestige raid because now the level
requirement is too high for them to ever
get to because they they can't get any
of the new gear so if you don't know how
destiny twos levels work there's two
level systems there's your core level
which is earned through XP maybe then
there's your power level which is
basically an overall average level of
all of your gun
and armor and that's that's what you use
to get into high-end activities and the
only way to get up to that 350 level is
to get the new equipment that's
available and curse for Cyrus so there
you go you can't get to it but it's also
it looks a little bit could be
problematic in the future because stuff
like the nightfall strike things that
come up so it's a random strike every
week it could be a no Cyrus centric
strike so if you don't have that DLC
you're not going to be able to do the
nightfall that week so stuff like that
is already starting to worry players and
they've been quite vocal about it on the
old reddit what do you think about this
Dan I know you have the exposure but
like that aside bias aside like what do
you think about it um I Justin he's a
weird one for me
because I remember this happening with
the first expansion the dark below on
destiny one and I've always thought of
destiny not as buying destiny 2 as that
being all of destiny 2 has to offer I
always thought that in order to get to
actually play destiny you have to buy
the expansions have such a problematic
sentence I know I agree and I and I
agree that that sucks like that is a
terrible way to look at it and stuff
like that that it's gonna lock you out
of all of these new activities I think
the fact that that's always been a
problem that Bungie has had you by
having stuff like nightfall strikes and
then introducing new strikes and
expansions I guess they would say it's a
way to try and get people to get on
board with the expansions because they
also fix a lot of things but it's a
problematic it's a problematic way to
design your game from from the get-go
telling people like I guess DLC is one
thing right being like you pick up curse
of Osiris you get extra single-player
content or something that makes sense to
me but letting people access things at
some stage and then locking them out
from it in the future because of what's
happened with the level cap adjustments
here seems like an issue
I will think if you want to access those
things again you need to dish out 20 30
bucks a will problem to play devil's
advocate because I know our audience
loves when I play devil's advocate these
activities that people are being looked
out from are quite high-end activities
like prestige nightfall and prestige
raid are something that a hardcore
destiny player would do not someone like
me
not someone like you we would probably
never ever get into the the press stage
though don't you think you can be a
hardcore destiny player without buying
the expansion I don't think so because
if you're are if you're a hardcore
destiny player you are we want to see
everything the destiny has to offer and
that unfortunately means buying those
expansions when they come out because
especially looking at the example of
destiny one when they brought out this
second expansion that completely changed
so much of the core game and added in so
much more content and things to do and I
do understand people are a little upset
about the amount of content that is in
destiny too and also the amount of
content that's on offer from curse of
Osiris so yeah I think it's it's a
really unfortunate time that Bungie
again haven't really learned any lessons
from destiny one and employed them in
any kind of meaningful way in destiny -
and it's clearly there the audience is
definitely saying yes as well as these
things sometimes go a Bungie did update
the situation after we shot this episode
they released a weekly blog post that
says we are aware that there are some
destiny - trophies and achievements that
have become unavailable to players who
have not purchased curse of Osiris we
are committed to fixing this issue and
are currently investigating a solution
please stay tuned for more updates on
this topic as progress is made we're not
sure exactly what they're gonna do or
haven't gonna rectify that problem but
it sounds like it's at least been
acknowledged as an issue that's
everything we have for you this week and
I'm sure we missed I bet you like Hideo
Kojima announced some like crazy David
Hayter like friggin cameos that
something at the games G that we've
missed out because we've shot this on
Thursday just before the game Awards
were on but PlayStation experience is
this weekend and weird GameSpot will be
covering all of that for you so please
do check in over the weekend for
everything from that and we will see you
guys on Monday do you remember all that
great content
yeah that's game of the year what you
don't speak in acronyms like we do what
will be game of the year let us know
what you reckon I reckon it's gonna be
you can't say because you know what I
game of the year is we'll see you next
week big news that we didn't come from
the game Awards because well we're
shooting this before the game watch yeah
but why would I be bringing a bunch of
news updates on site throughout the game
awards and we're streaming alive
which means nothing to you because it's
in the past that's oh
[Applause]